okay welcome I i'm professor gene common
from the political science department
but in a different different information
I'll associative as Michelle Walker and
it is a great pleasure to introduce me
Shelly Walker to you our problem is
pronouncing did teach yoga but
and I just found that to my utter songs
me that this is the first time he has
come to columbia which is a scandal for
a sociologist it won't be the last time
whether his first time and it's about
time in any case i met before i think
almost 30 years ago alarming in the
context of work on social Moses
we shall order
now the plan for this way it was a
member of cadiz which was the lab
working group of
by Atlanta man and he became the
director of the the center in 1981
Michelle Orca stepped down in that
position in 2009 to become the director
of the fungus young made AA desi on
Stallone which all you could realize
an important institution in France
and he is currently also a professor and
pushes SBA koleos
among other physicians but these are the
main ones now right he is the author of
many many books he's on the board many
many journals books at the transmissions
English many of them among I cannot be
small let's take up the entire town
lecture but starting to invoke I'm they
tally that's when I they talk about her
will 1977
and culminating in a book which I think
just came out called for that portion
both dimensions y las cosas de champlain
without box with eternal which is
command 2011 clearance will be have some
sons
in between just so you know the range of
the world is written on and directed
major work on social movements on
religion I multiculturalism I'm probably
leaving something out in any case I'm
pleased and honored that Michelle
provoke is fun G with an old friend as
each me understand it's really a
pleasure to be here to meet some friends
Risa trains or the train and with many
strands my first having hello yeah for
me New York stops moralism 6206 5th
string something like that another nose
northern part of Manhattan for me I did
not know before so it's a discovery and
listen process is a wonderful place I
want to censor people cendien can make
yourself not be here tonight organize my
visit here so before really starting
this what I want to help you I just want
to tell you it's not an introduction
it's a precision I am now in my country
as being left politically left-oriented
but what I'm going to say which is
connected with cease but as is not
political I mean is not a politician
French people would say Satan analysis
maybe somebody who would be more right
oriented could make the same kind of
analysis but for the right that I'm
going to say further that I family bet
it I'm not going to defend any any left
tinnitus that
and I I did tonight is to tell you that
I think that the moment has come in some
countries at least I don't want to
generalize to match but in some
countries at least my country France and
other European countries and I'm seeing
about each other first of all the moment
has come to try to see why the left is
so weak or has so many difficulties to
appear as it sometimes I've said in
other historical movements my ID is
trying to say something like we should
try to collect political orientations in
my guess left right so thought we should
try to articulate these orientations
with what social ecology or social
science can bring how can we collect
sociological analysis and political
convictions to say later and maybe if we
try to do this maybe we can have new
ideas and maybe we could I don't know
the English word is a French translating
vice versa los reyes aunt mo na to renew
the read the range sentiment of politics
so this is I think that maybe social
science can contribute to this reaction
and this is what I
trying to say tonight so I went in about
100 parties democracy Europe excuse me
turn in a bit atma centrica and Mattias
Hobart very airtime is no process though
even a duty to get no centrica and to
connect political analysis and just
vertical axis my first point with the
odd politics as we all think maybe this
could be discussed the idea of democracy
came from old grease with Christina so
long and then arrived Roman then was
part of European spirit then went to
America Western world as we say and to
the edge of democracy classical wave
speed is supposed to be good for to move
in fact it is maybe not so true is
touring the league if you read a naughty
asain and from your very important or
sir if you read about yourself he said
once the idea of democracy you can find
it also in Africa you can find it also
in India and so it's not necessary this
classic color but ok so if you consider
Western Europe the idea of democracy has
been strong since many centuries
of course you can say that it was there
the old time but what is important for
what I'm going to present now he
certified that during the interest to
the classical industrial era the idea of
democracy began connected with social in
a very important and this is my starting
but if you want to understand the growth
of democracy in Europe and maybe here
the growth of the idea of democracy you
have to consider what happened socially
with industrial society at the time of
industrialization that is to say as a
time when the social company structure
collected by the conflict between the
working class movement and the Masters
of industry because other with this
company is complete accident which was a
social conflict between social actors
semesters of industry as a trade unions
workers this conflict was social but
added political dimensions or a
political correspondence and this is how
the lead from my point of view became so
in future in many countries and here to
mothers appeared through twin brothers
or two
you can say the mother as a child or the
22 brother the center two mothers of
democracy connected and political action
connected with social issue could
develop in Europe winter second half of
her aunty century in an editor and this
is the starting point on the one hand
social democracy and what the other hand
what became community social democracy
from my point of view it's very
difficult because you can define it as a
concept or you can define it
historically and it's not necessary that
existed but historical social democracy
was a strong will because movement
strong trade unions if you prefer and a
political party which is the expression
of the trade unions you can have it in
Scandinavia angular it in Germany in
England was a little bit different to
add lots of references can writing a
strong social force which is expressed
politically by a party which is the
correspondence as political level of the
social movement so the first product was
social democracy we stood characteristic
the first one is that the political
party is supposed to be the expression
of the tragic
and the second characteristic is that
the political party is democratic is
willing to win so forward to get access
to power through elections through
negotiation suit ebay not through
violent group jus just ricotta model is
what you can call communism communities
model which is a mother person because
we're the political party is supposed to
get access to cover including my sister
that including through violence so
evolution and what happened with the
Communists mother is at her in a kind of
reversal because it was a rather quickly
and it was true obviously after nineteen
seventeen at the duration revolution the
Communist Party is supposed to be more
important than the social movement and
the trade unions and much more important
so that some time to Communist Party
considered that working-class that the
trade unions are not important and
should not be more than a ton awesomest
expression that cool water cost me see
on the transmission bed of your part
with the culture
I don't have time to be more precise it
is not very important what is important
is that today in Western Europe at least
it is no longer possible to driven to
these models communism is my point of
view salary of course you will meet some
communism where you will need some
communist party somewhere in my country
the Communist Party still exists in
Italy it does not exist anymore as such
the name has changed but in my country
for instance after the circle to draw
the curve in his body was to more
important political force in the country
with 26 or 28 percent of the voters the
first elations today is three or four
percent of the porters and there is no
capacity to mobilize
22 to propose a shoot you through this
button so it's yen for my point of view
it's the end of communism and social
democracy also is declining in Europe
it's declining maybe not as an ideal
later a dream but it's declining for two
reasons the main one is that surround or
longer strong trade unions able to
support a political party I went at the
French case which is very clear in
France today no more than seven percent
and maybe less of the workers belong to
trade unions sale and where do they work
these people not so much in industry
mess for a civil service for the state
as school teachers with the
administration massive order in the
industry so it means that it means that
there is no load no not
more so the social movement which can be
expressed in in a political action as a
certain party services I take forward to
say that where is that social democracy
means the welfare state or something
like that and today we know after so
many years of neoliberalism and so on we
know that it's more and more difficult
to a welfare state so for better the
main reason is the decline of social
force that was corresponding to the
political force so for this reason the
left in a country like my country that
it destroys on it early and in many
other country Hampshire sur les today as
lost its two main political matters so
it's difficult to be strong in elections
if you don't have such important moments
and the problem for the left this is
what I'm not trying to do that would be
to propose something new my situation
where is a new classical
collapse decline disappear it is not
totally true that nothing new was tested
in the days of 90 in Sri country yet
some people that tried to proper
something that you could consider as
something new in this country Clinton in
Germany shredder and England and his
more famous one Tony Blair with the
server sociologist acting the Lord
intelligence which means that sometimes
social scientists I can I directly
connected for it not always so it is
true it it is true that something there
was something which was tested in order
to create on seeing you but as you know
even until he didn't say that it is
finished maybe and read from article on
televisions but rather recently various
way that it's reached so the program is
at today so left
the field more less than right is as to
be reinvented recreated
in a situation where so amazing I've
changed I will be a little bit more
precise with one second but under one
hun today it is no not mobile possible
to sync politically like people used to
say in the fifties but in the city for
one very big reason which is the total
drag work cannot agree only on manly so
nationalistic maybe you know a very
important German sociologist polish bay
yes a wonderful expression you say we
must finish with methodological
nationalism that is to say we must not
consider that summation of a nation
state is necessarily the framework for
any political of sociological analysis
because globalization and also because
rancid rebuilding of Europe or me or
stand of you traitor Union but mainly
because many problems today are closed
many problems need to be sick at a
global
and not only at the level of the
nation-state and add sir and this is
great with the latest edition state or
we see the forever over some political
scientist called the Westphalian model
that is to say you maybe you remember
that in 1648 in Europe was westphalian
trade treaties that decided that the
world in fact Europe should be organized
in nations and with international
relations so this model nations and
international relations is not able to
enter to understand so many issues
ecological issues justice global justice
having many problems we must sink at a
global level and not visitor friendly as
a nation state that politics are
national and yet when you vote for a
political party it is within the forever
of your nation state so how can we do to
make politics is a framework for
political action can no longer be only
you're mentally maybe the nation-state
these are some one reason for the first
reasons that difficult the
reconstruction
and there is another set of reasons that
we precise now that make the
reconstruction of the less difficult it
is that today you are more and more
issues that Albert classical to tell me
you better open eyes so left to define
some position religion and culture are
becoming more and more important in our
collective right and the left is rather
able to do is economy social with
problems of pensions for web of social
exclusion problem of exploitation in the
workplace and so on but when you have to
deal with recogen when you have to deal
with identities when you have to deal
with memories all these issues the left
is not so automatically ever to pro
answers so the one hand mobilization and
its consequences for the framework
political tension and party other than
the development of new issues of new
progress religion and capture autism
difficult really for the left so fair
judgment the reaction from all that is
necessary so this one my first point
just to tell you it's not so easy to
make proposals related my second point I
would like to give you my perception of
the evolution of the social science I
told you the social science with here
for sebastia are supposed we could maybe
contribute to this renewal of ID's
what's at work within the social sites
from my image I will start with the 60s
of the late 50s the 60s where a kind of
golden era of course we said we must
always be careful when we speak of the
past in terms of golden time
time is always mythical we know that a
social time but there was something very
important at that time the social
science we are providing very general
ideas and not only precise and limited
knowledge at that time from a strategies
country there was a cathedral by process
all I mean the young generation don't
study Parsons anymore but my generation
had to read positive twas very playful
and it was a cathedral a huge
construction with Ducan Max Weber
Marshall and son and it's a huge huge
chasm but was not the only general
theory for society you could be or not a
Marxist you could be ordered a
structuralist you could be a Marxist as
another say that returns you could be
some time mark systems which are distant
from shuttle is that so I don't want to
discuss
but there was a theoretical level maybe
this theoretical never was in full with
ideology but it existed which meant that
you could be a researcher in social
science working on a precise issue you
could be enjoyed by the no education
process or hands or guns or whatever
your work which was reading the
necessary limited could be part of a
very general theory you could say I am
working on education and I have a
functionalist or am I so you could start
from a precise problem or issue and go
to general political and historical
theory and this was very important
because you didn't have only the
possibility to go from limited issued
more general perspective or from general
perspective to more limited issue you
could also participate in several face
Marxist non Marxist and so on in my
country vs people
in two or three class because he had to
choose muah home shopper self-interest
to give you example of big series so
this was the situation in the sixties
and early seventies 20 case but then
things started to change and we are we
living during the 7280 the 19th a kind
of decomposition of this classical model
for social sense the kind of physical
education and not only a dissipation of
this model but the desegregation of the
IT to harm others to add General
Patton's center west or to analyze of
course I know more what was at stake in
securities and other disciplines but I
know that it is more or less what
happening our apologies for instance or
in linguistic front in a positive entity
so what happened first brother soon some
people say out there is a crisis in
social science
is very interesting today nobody say
that there's a crisis into social but at
that time some people say there is a
crisis I remember a very very good and
famous book flight AnnaLynne good nerve
the title is very interesting the coming
crisis it's not totally surprising is
coming the coming crisis of Western
society it's very interesting because
what I just was published in two very
early seventies it's very interesting
because this book by goodner is
explaining why parsons should be totally
forgotten yeah and it's very choosy the
demonstration surgical demonstration was
that so many things were happening in
America at that time the vietnam war
after the movement for the CP right and
so on so many social political movement
where happening in society that the
general model of forces could not work
anymore so this was a thesis by a good
just the parenthesis is very interesting
today to see that matter was the other
great functionaries at that time
did not propose of B cathedral-like
father he proposed middle ranch theory
you know so as a technique was not as or
not as possible but today nathan is
coming back and passionately but this is
a parenthesis forces of an interesting
story of identity so the first ID of a
crisis came when people say it's faster
is finished after that you have some
people that try to play also to propose
a real short mock of passes my friend a
Jeffrey Alexander tried for the new casa
de that he collapsed and he recognizes
me that it was not possible so 20 years
after he was a loser formulation of this
idea of the crisis and you can find it
in different text that's more
interesting from minor to you is a lot
of sociology so then this evening always
who published the book the title of
which is the pickup position of
sociology I thought the coming crisis so
the table position and the main idea is
that sociology is being in a process of
deco position because it is less and
less Universalist it is more and more
dominated by relativity that is to say
diets such a vivid sociologist that
don't connect together in a Motorhome
and within all of it makes me remember
my I did not come recently in a bookshop
in an American University butcher but a
few years ago going in an American
University bookshop was very interesting
processors you go to the sociology
department very all the books to see a
room full of full of dust the bottom do
nothing very new data say that then you
go to Holocaust Studies gay lesbian
studies african-american studies gay and
lesbian attend that is to say you don't
have security as a universal discipline
you have specific issues and this can
lead very quickly to relative in that
you to say forgetting universal values
so it's very interesting to resist but I
and this movement of the competition you
can you can maybe the describe it in a
little bit more precise we're adding
some phones first of all this tech
opposition meant that many social
scientists said ok let us forget correct
theory the ecology let's forget it small
is beautiful
let us go far from politics let us go
far from the history for instance it was
during the 70 that much more 80s and 90s
in my country at least many people give
us other strong interest for all this
family of sociology that you can call I
know that have been different but it's
the same time Edna methodology
phenomenological sociology so-called
school of Palo Alto me all these
characters and it's very interesting Oh
mr. Bester social assistance is famine
years old was the government and cousin
man used to say very clearly yes I know
my sister she has nothing to do with
politics my sociology has nothing to do
with history I know it I am NOT
interested by me by 40 store mr.
Endicott not telling it ignited a small
is beautiful that you wanted to study
limited interactions and since I sit so
yet is your other people that say well
there is no more society we just have
emptiness you just we we don't have
anything Morse society we just add
individuals and it was a moment when
some people
let us develop the project of
methodological individualism this can go
aggies became brothers so the mains
puerile was a spirit of the composition
of sociology and so as I try to say it
started in the early 70s and it is not
really a dancer was another spirit that
was taking place not as visible but she
says pretend like to promote a period of
reconstruction of some Civic and I would
like to say that this reconstruction for
me I went to interesting stages I don't
I don't want any misunderstanding I will
not defend the idea that I'm going to
quote now that's it for me say where
Pato says yeah I said we should
reconstruct or ribbon son so first idea
which was a very influential in the 80s
and 90s was the edge of hospitality
today is finished today live in trees
you should take your ass to do that if
you say that you are going to write
about prosperity it's not fashionable
don't do that first two days
I policy but it was very interest it was
interesting because it introduced a
debate what does it mean personality
it's money but it's after been connected
with modernity and from its eid that the
new Europe is made of tensions between
identities emotions patience and so on
Joanna and it is a universal values know
right and reason so it's a Western
debatable hospitality and the Second
Amendment which was interesting for me
more recently but unfortunately the main
securities here died was the idea of
multiple identities it's ashwin items
that who died a few months ago I thought
I were being close to passers in the 60s
or something like that but it isn't
society because it did not like a very
important person and piety which was
hideous conversions and modernization
that is to say all societies more I
should convert the same kind of murder
of modernity God and
evolution defect that all society really
becomes mother Morris to say and what
Eisenstein say but there are separate
identities melody from validity of
course is introduced a very interesting
debate but shouldn't receive as rate
only one modernity but different paths
wouldn't different ways of modernization
we can discuss candle but for me the
beginning of the reconstruction but this
is not in dust and this is whatever and
see why would like to introduce more
precise maybe more interesting I and
here is where for me is the new image
that we can ask for social self so if
you accept this image of decomposition
and prices of the one some before ever
some efforts to discuss modernity
medical modality but you better you say
if you want to see what is really new
and building this spiral of
reconstruction I think that you must go
and study to protect into account two
different issues that seem touch
overheat and let in fact are connected
the first important qualities eid of
globalization and the second important
point is the ideal individual opening
offices subject the individual data
search so under 100 ization she's very
cheddar doc and the other and the other
at CIT of subject which is great see you
who have been possible I think that the
twenties are connected i would say i
would say why using a few sir so first
my first point is that today more and
more we are organized not to analyze
globalization but to seek global is not
exactly the same i consider that
globalization as a phenomena its foreign
columnist much more than for other
people I mean they can study seeker
as good but for all their social
scientist you want to consider economy
as a social science for both the social
scientists I see that the program is not
to paralyze commodity it is to be able
to analyze social issues from a global
perspective that is 217 taking into
account various levels of analysis from
some more general the global world
everyone to the more local and this is
very important for many phenomena that
seem to be only local if you take this
personal to you and you try to sync
global you will understand it's
different so many problems they're low
culture so the social issues so many
problems can be very local and at the
same time you cannot really understand
them if you don't take into account so
more general dimensions of this product
so this first ID that globalization
means that we must sing globally society
is more and more effective
in the social science but everybody and
of course and it's not as clear in some
countries as it is in other countries
result in my country the people who did
not like did not want to discuss
mobilization until recently and we
invented another girl in front the movie
and less humid on secular organization
and it's a for me to kind of resistance
physics but ok so the one hand I think
that normal poor people except she says
it is useful to analyze people very
limited phenomenon taking into account
various levels of analysis including the
more general that you can go to global
world under one
and on the other hand there is a huge
tendency within the social time I
started in the 80s there is a huge
tendency to take seriously two gone the
notion of subject subjectivity
subjective Asian distance education yet
a new vocabulary of a renewed vocabulary
that trying to take all these categories
the safety that is to say to try to
understand what is social life tarting
the perspective of the individual as a
subject that is to say as able to become
an amateur a subject is a quality which
means the capacity of action it is not
because about you don't you are not
necessarily an actor if you're a sorry
but your movies capacity or you would
like to discuss it I don't have time to
be more precise but I just want to give
a certain number of
if you take people working on Rachel
they will tell you in the past religion
was terminated biological reproduction
parents were Catholic or misleading
modules or systems lab so children are
because of a person to 10 more and more
people say my religion is my personal
choice as a subject I have many friends
at work into French servers as I study
the use into friendships many of them
many of the young people are making and
when they asked young people you're
missing can you explain me what does it
mean what is it the answers very
frequently it is my choice it's my
decision of course I will set up to you
about the parents to grant feathers and
so on of course that's the idea digital
person and she said the religion is
connected with that and this is why
people can exchange can pass for every
religion too
religion I will give you a very friends
and very limited that interesting
example maybe you have heard that in
friends we had affairs of both cards a
total fail you know woman with them most
of the movement that I've been
interviewed I don't say altered woman
but most of the women that have been
interviewed by fossil scientist I have
to to deserving the PhD on this they are
they were tested they were carefully and
very fresh so that they can Sleiman our
liners by Canseco so he is very
interesting it mean it's a personal
choice what why and how this is another
problem so religion has something to do
more and more with subjective now let me
take another case work when I was a
student when we were dealing with work
work it it meant exploitation like
social relations in a factory the
workplace domination today with ya your
work is in the French
is discussed it's not so much
exploitation something different it's
cid that work should mean creativity
capacity to build is on trajectory to be
master of what you do and so on but
sometimes it is not possible and
sometimes it's so impossible that you
will have the feeling to be arrest or to
be Auto suffer yeah your surgery is very
important as you more extreme case if is
when people commit suicide at a
workplace we had a lot of debating
friends about this issue because when
people commit suicide at your workplace
it means something about work but if you
commit suicide yet as an individual and
you have as a subject that cannot exist
of the color transform be transformed
into an actor so you can connect this ID
or this is where thinking about work
with the idea of subjective I could take
many other exam for exams today many
people
special status a very important to study
the body to study what people do with
them what people want to do with their
body it's totally different that what
well say 30 or 40 years ago the body 30
or 40 years ago was mainly the
sociological literature somebody of
exploited workers suffering being an eel
services while many perm missing Lana
Cena men she was so important and so and
yeah I J was so important so so today
it's different people for that statue
body setup is very touchy because we the
dance sport which tattoo with appear
seeing another people want to master
their own body and to do something about
them to express something from server
their subjectivity so I could take many
many other cases or examples i will say
a little bit
classically when you when you say I have
an interest for education you study the
system the educational system when you
are an interest for health is that is a
medical system more and more people say
no what is important also is to study
but only the educational system but the
student or the pupil as such or to study
not only the medical system better in
person not only illness but in and to
take it 62 and if you listen to take
another example all these people that
work on identities no Sheldon we could
discuss many people will say that
working on identity means understanding
why did well as a feeling to be victims
from its recent the notion of victim
which is calling that which is not so
far from the emotional subject it did
not exist or almost not 40 useful so I
don't want to get too long here but I
think this is what I wanted
is when I said I've seen that the
reconstruction of social science as a
lot to do with the capacity of the
researchers to deal with two extreme
opposite problem or category
globalization and subjectivity and as I
told you two are not only opposite you
don't you're not a chapter they are not
English rather you are not like that you
know only because I think that's a
mooring leaving the global world the
more maybe you will try to exist as a
subject in order to face system and this
is why the debate about human rights so
important because human right it's a
very local issue but it's also
very
so
dead space remember i started with the
crisis of the left of the good mothers
for the left I don't say that there is a
crisis for social science when I when
people try to say that there is a crisis
for social science car right but not
it's not an intellectual problem it's
much more than institutional problem or
for them over with so many I am sure
more of the same in this country so many
people have got a PhD and then they
don't find a job I was really recently
some statistics very interesting in the
pasture much more in proportion much
more people with Antonio is a stable
position than today so this can yes
these are real problem but
intellectually I don't you people saying
that we are social scientist in an
intellectual crisis
any problem and I 18 now and I'll also
my Ally to say try to see if as I told
you if social science as they are today
after this take a position beginning to
be revealed within notions of
globalization and destruction of subject
and many many many other notions of who
couldn't save an element in order to
contribute to to rebuild to repeat the
political life on selected and it's not
so easy a lot of problem but it is clear
that we bring knowledge that first of
all I will take the French debate we are
debating today for instance about Islam
Francis it's an obsession in France
Islam is very central issue in my
country
and if we wanted to make seriously and
to make good qualities as far as it's
time for take and maybe we don't know
that later but maybe five or six minion
misleading people in my country it's a
lot so if you want to take it we must
know entities Islam and how people come
Leslie or army Muslim problem or want to
know more to be missing and how to
connect their Islam is what is at stake
in other countries and so we need Social
Research awesome science research and
many people doing very very well and so
in many cases such sessions and can
bring some light on the problems that
are discussed at the political level so
problem for the left and its signals
right that one on many issues people
don't know what is to be left at what
department to be right if you say lazy
difference divided you should take
nation if you take islam shoot a
treasure
if you take multiculturalism antenna you
will need very important or positions
conflict with the left and wheezing the
right so how social science can be
helpful if all these issues are very
cool feature than she are a lot of now
in order not to bring a solution but
just to give an example and we take one
issue to say to see to try to see are we
can discuss / just one example but
before efficacies example i just like to
add something one of the problem is the
problem of categories this is a
pro-level vocabulary in when we face all
these new issues or recent issues as
Americans it's at least that we use we
don't we can touch good to us so what do
we do it when we don't have to go to us
we created you with so we use a lot of
post now
trance I mean both this small element
that you put it before you know the same
it's not exactly it has something to do
it's much more much less it is got
mcnabb in heart to heart so what is when
do to try to create some new vocabulary
and the second problem for me is worth a
very important problem is that we use
into social science sometimes the same
words words that are used is a public
debate my example will be also a little
onesies
I would like to finish detectives the
example of the notion of integration
because it's a very classical notion for
sociology of social side and it's part
of the public debate in my country very
lives I want to say something which will
be maybe a very rude of her excessive
but I consider that the notion of
integration from a sociological
perspective is very classic
old-fashioned you should forget it
Foreman and from a political perspective
is reactionary so you can be short but
I'm frightened I said in a very extreme
we're just drop the description but just
to tell you how the social science can
brings medicine if you take the social
science you take your time or parcels
the classical also they use a lot in
idea of integration citv that the more
society is integrated so better Seoul s
foreign some people will come in suicide
suicide
to Ken's demonstration discuss it or not
do you can't demonstration about suicide
it is society's is connected with a less
integrated collective way of life so the
ideas integration in classical sociology
is connected with the idea society in
instant L&T the problem is society the
problem the art is not the triple the
individual of course we idea integration
that comes easy ideas within society of
socialization of individual and if you
are socialized say you will become an
individual but the main purpose is the
society as a rule this is what is
important this is why the classical
sociology dealing with society of
integration when it studies me grunts as
no interest for the country where demons
are coming from and there's no interest
for the trajectory of the migrant
between the portal
the point of arrival what is important
is not to be run what is important is
the integration of the society so it is
not important to know if these people
suffer or if they don't suffer it's not
important to know it is people are
building something new or not it's a
threat if they are bringing new forms of
culture is that creating new let resin
under the program is is society more or
less integrated this is from being not
so good security because I cinta to sync
suffering more interesting when you have
an interest for Madrid is to do how to
do they go in the country in order to
cross this country transit or to stay in
the country do they go back do they
participate in network to say after
feeling or continue yes Laura Tuesday
participating new cultural invention I
mean so many things can be said about
vegan that are very important as I able
to to build their own life or not as
well so if you deal with the notion of
integration is not important
utility with society as a totality so
for me social science may use this
version of integration that sociology
class a classroom you have box light
system files it's a very classical
society that does not understand what is
new at the world ever which is new when
you take into account of subjectivity as
one now listen to the political
discourse in my country
it's very very interesting integration
is used in order to set different
because it is a but it has you must be
integrated and if you don't want to be
integrated go back in your country and
if you don't want to be integrated I
will send you the police because that's
all I can do so integration in my
country is connected with 26 eternity
scores maybe you can touch re that
because you don't know Trevor and as you
did not work because people say are you
asked me to be integrity but I don't
have any results for it I don't have a
job I am a victim of racism I am living
in a ghetto and I would you wanted me to
be integrated if you don't if you don't
give me the possibility to detail so
teacher discuss it has not well so is it
is closed as doctors say I don't agree
and there is a moment when you have
riots winter servers support suburbs
during three weeks which was the case I
years ago are in a situation of
to Tyler viola and so on and I went went
to the forward to geology to do is to
send the police or Giambi into that
preparation and if you if you listen you
will see that this discourse of
integration is more and more used by
politicians with that when they don't
have any other solution reaction to
these solar problem solvers suburbs on
you and so on
this is so true that people try to find
mother in my dead mother's of
integration and don't find it and here
and then we finish with too much and
here is very dressy to try and manage
the story it's a real story in 29 2005
in London as you may remember they wear
terrorist attacks the first one
succeeded the second one trial but it
was clear very quickly that the people
that made attack we are not coming from
abroad like the people that have done
September even know they were born in
England and so this was perceived as a
consequence also more British or English
model of integration which was described
as community Camino terrorists at a loss
a team is very whether this mother sir
not very stern as was said at that time
you know this possibility for Islam
preachers in churches to say often say
that such as this mother did not work
until the French
interfaces newspapers get some
intellectuals and political actors that
for the articles look at this English
people or British people they they were
so proud of their mother our fresh
father is quite bitter because of
terrorist attack now let's recon jester
in front we are in the southern 33 which
these riots and it's the English daily
newspapers you could find articles it
was afraid reserved Adele but
effectively kannazhaga it's not better
and possible right I mean there is
nobody that works in a country like the
Netherlands they had this kind of modern
British style
and because then I Reuters not very
don't want so today I think that Jo my
bed until I saw integrated model society
itself it has not worry Adam and the
problem for me not to create you
mother's probably soon to develop new
politics new places and new policy not
policies to integrate people but to give
to the people of England resources in
order for them to build their online and
then baby that is not a problem for me
to be integrated so I want to just to
take this example we discuss most okay
see where other wonder at the 100
sociological analysis can provide
different perspectives classical or new
and political discourse and action can
provide also illustration which is very
and I think that's a political actors
they want to be to build a new left
which is my ID is they want to be
something you on the left they should
take very seriously into a dumb is a new
ways of thinking that our dividend
universal sense horse is attempted to
propose tonight for decisions
so well thank you very much and the
fourth of
anything of yours oh thank you very much
also ending on your last note about a
new possibility of politics and
particularly since you mentioned this
whole question of integration I'll make
the argument well I've been hearing in
the last two weeks that what happened in
Tunisia Egypt now leads to neha open
because of the connection with France
that done a lot of the myths of Middle
East culture has been shall we say
proven redundant and thus wondering it
combined the latest crisis with your
foreign minister about a wonderful
connections weather
this can lead to some kind news
beginning of the new paradigm Milo and
go as far as a new paradigm of some kind
of new interpretations you have court
I'm sorry you rest in your license what
happens in North Africa in a cheat and
so what as a social scientist for me
it's wonderful of course I am blind I
understood that some problems could
arise but to say very briefly I have the
same feelings that I had with solidarity
appeared importantly 1980s I remember
something very well because people are
casually bigger than so maybe it was
wonderful social movement and it was the
beginning to collapse of the Soviet
empire so in front of this if you take
the French case it's a caricature the
French the French league political
leaders not only did not understand you
not that it did not imagine imagine
anything the others should keep behavior
you not of extreme game that you could
see our minister of foreign actor
minister forever going to Tunisia during
the event and meeting some private
meeting some very rich friend of the
President I'm going into private plane
of this person and what I said recently
yesterday the newspaper and visitings is
very rich person Fred of the finale in
order to buy some decisions on some Java
from a two digit different position a
second case making much more interesting
the Prime Minister the Prime Minister
when Mubarak said I finished I agree he
said ah we must consider that this man
did it very with a very elegant way so
you have a popular movement of a social
movement of a democratic movement at all
and you are political who were not only
Elizabeth pork I don't understand
certain so it's very interesting to say
it would be great on the left vision
myself if people could understand
the problem is that they don't
understand so much better I arrived
yesterday and in the plane I read a
newspaper with a long interview of her
somebody with Minister of Foreign
Affairs we selected the government and I
was absolutely shocked because what
listened was said he said what happened
to the area was unpredictable subtly and
predictable now let me tell you what we
have her doing so next 20 years so this
arrogance or somebody who said what
happened yesterday was unpredictable
that I can tell you that you master the
next heir of your 20th so imagine
issuances I mean we might not accept of
course the knowledge that we can bring
on a perfect and at if you read is very
interesting if you read what researchers
that know what is at stake in Egypt or
Tunisia
or not i have read wonderful article
that was pitted and you just one example
to feel there is a very very well known
specialist fresh specialist with Olivia
world is very good I read a very
interesting article because people were
saying oh but is doing isn't it possible
that in Egypt or in Tunisia this
movement become an established both man
and a big danger for Enzo and he said
the people that are in the street in
edgy today Arthur sent people that
protested in Iran one year ago against
two must be born in you exactly we
further taking both countries it has
more interesting that just up can we
become Islamism babies learn stuff you
can I don't know listen so this is where
as consider that we as social scientists
we can participate much more in the
public debate with solid ID the time is
no longer a time when sucked dry
could go to Japan from Perth up could go
to Japan and give very famous conference
lectures about what is to be an
intellectual and he said an intellectual
is somebody key so give this turkey
below Alton okay well today I social
scientists we can we have to express
ourselves when we are concerned because
we know because there isn't it the case
when as contents of reasons
certain power and this power bills are
just isn't there conflict of your
argument subjective and fat a standard
research and this power you need to
invest discuss but you are absolutely
right side social site are not
monolithic Allah they are big tensions I
have I have a disciple of Allah to hand
it was a question of death and life with
border between Joanne and gaudy original
ready so I'd like that but I came far
from the T sequence of boy or even if I
can have very good friends among said so
of course you are big differences but
you have to pass if it is a good social
side
it is able to discuss with other people
not necessary to find an agreement but
to know better what is your position
between three and then what is important
is the knowledge that we shall bring so
forever is not to lose to have this
writer think juice right so problem is
on such or such issue what does a
research made by to read brandy and
water research and I will be more
precise in the second and water research
led by Roger breathe I give an example
in one of the last important books by
Roger horse called the nomination was
really the male domination I don't know
how to attention it's a boob where would
you say something like I exaggerator to
be women are victims of symbolic
violence they are dominated so much by
men that they in turn your eyes the
categories of the terminal you until
your eyes at the category of the
definite we cannot seek by yourself with
that there is no feminism and no action
no possible action for woman is in Terry
Stephanie domination I exaggerated no no
I exaggerate I know I told you I
I know but it's not as if I say it's not
but theoretically it's not possible and
I remember because in my Center we had a
very strong feminist for instance France
well yes but she was a she was really
founded of Roger that she's booked she
said no he said I cannot exist us so but
what to randy was totally different ten
years after or five years after he
published a book which is attacker in
francis remove the fact we were and he
made a finger with mber and he said
woman wants to be subject okay I don't
say even if i have my opinion I don't
say you must follow Trevor and for him
to HSA take what would you say and and
try to see if it is useful for you to
see politically or to suppress them and
a feminist and take what Torres so
that's it but it is true that it's very
good future and to follow what you say
listening to you I cycling economies are
much more monolithic ax and was a social
scientist so he's a so-called mainstream
it's very interesting because this
mainstream men wasn't absolutely not
able to think what happened in two
thousand
surprises but there was a kind of
consensus among economies to sing always
in the same so it's better to have
conflict differences and so on and today
anyway and that's what I think he said
what we can bring to politicians of
political life is not greet social
scientists all agree on the reason not
to tell that things are not so easy
these are true perspective or three
different perspective so you should take
this into account and try to find your
your wing thinking so I agree with you
there is no consensus and the sugar
I'm going to put myself on the lip
I'm thinking that I'm a good must
diagonals
right and I to question about if they
really interrelated the first well well
with regards to the left and the
trajectory or what could in some sense
regenerative politics or what would
revise and in a way it's sort of unsere
what the less the concept means as a
result of your and thats I and analysis
so i would think that I'm something that
one one issue or 11 dimension of this
project would be we would have to tell
articulation at least have some projects
or principles for noise sorry Elizabeth
young well let's put that with projects
that would differentiate a left from
inama I don't think that's impossible to
do I wouldn't I don't think that's
possible to do at all but I think that
would have to be in other words not
necessarily a grand social theory which
has seen the truth in his back pocket
etc but this dimension
is indispensable and then the second
thing would be and I don't think I also
don't think would be impossible to do
how would that link up with or how could
you lift it up with some of these
dimensions that you mentioned for
example the issue of the subject I don't
take this as this about the foucauldian
discourse of such activation as the
effective power it's the opposite but
what's really interesting to me is the
way in which you described the behind
the border and France far they are
Catholics know what I mean by that is
that or where you go and you find out
about as this was a religion it's my
choice that sounds to me like like
something that none sociologist
diagnosed actually because a cast ever
it sounds like the denominator is a shin
I denominationalism from church to
denomination of religion also as you
describe it of Muslims and France that's
a huge community and so that means that
that means to thin voluntary choice
voluntary Association and a fool well
supposedly the subject so so in
being not simply being the product as
you said of the parents how could how
are you how do you link these up and
it's a fascinating idea that also means
of course that that that the voluntary
part is would in some sense prevail over
the course apart which is still there to
this virtual coercion so I'm curious i
mean i think that the burden would be
all over again I think
to articulate a conception because you
have to do that in other words of the
absence of grand fear that is the
essence of a good public of a articulate
able project for people will not be a
perfect answer because at that straight
as you understand it's not so easy that
I can say here is a problem I am Not
sure that I can say here it is a
solution but I would fit three things
first off first of all I think that we
can pass from the individual subject as
an individual 20 policies if we
introduce a very simple ID which is you
cannot be the subject if you don't
consider that everybody should be able
to be a subject so if you had read this
principle then you introduce the notion
of collective responsibility so the idea
that the role of politicians is create a
condition so that everybody could be
considered as a subject and would be
given as much as possible commissions to
business so this would be
on my second point is that if dealing
with this version of Zurich if we want
left text seriously the idea of
subjectivity subject and so on of course
we are not in the classical image of
negative lab like big groups
connectivity and so on but it is
possible to connect the idea of
collective responsibility and the idea
of individual subjectivity I give you an
example I have been proposing to the
socialist but another member of the
Socialist Party but I dishes this would
be my cell phone I discuss a lot with it
I got was there to introduce the notion
of I said if right service public person
is a public service but taking into
account each individual that is to say
the French like very much a notion of
Capri services very frightened but shuts
have to be in France now for this
example it means that the public service
should not be some secret she's done by
anonymous people and that tricks
everybody anonymous it's possible to
take seriously each person as such each
requires one hand and each people that
want to be a customer of Railways
transportation or whether so telleo
service too because this kind of Heidi
that try to connect the two damaged but
now I will go to my men and the third
part which is if my IDs could be useful
each wins such a relationship between
intellectuals of researchers and
politicians or political actors or
political parties should be renewed and
my and my ID is that what is a friends
episode like that is a French debate
many people used to say how left has no
ID so that is not true you go on blogs
internet if you read the pages i TS
opinion and sony is a newspaper everyday
have lots of ideas the problem is not
the difficulty the problem is how can
you create dynamic between
researchers method produce or break the
eighties and politician and this is not
so easy that you must create places
where the Ponte skirt places where
people work together people the problem
is that politicians at no time as a
problem possession intellectual
researchers say since are very complex
and politicians say we did very simple
idea but my experience is that is that
it is possible to have this kind of but
it takes time accessories
we are talking about the people in the
segment academy I know as a former
president of the International
sociological association or American
writer with public sociology
it sounds like you're advocating for
that not just
social scientists do research that
somehow has mysteriously popped the
attention of politicians but that we
more actively
pursue that attention with our research
is that what you had in mind in terms of
practice where we know
with understanding
and creating a kind of a different world
see all the structures of the our nation
nation states and so on from research
what my first of all the expression
permit sociology was corridor at least
used by my cover boy we took my
expression that I don't feel so far
electrical that I don't feel really
taxes because Michael / / has a
political project moment to discuss it
we should not my case so what is very
important for me is each to say
something unsafe Liza is to say that's
the demonstration in sociology it is not
like in Natural Science we don't make
experiences we can demote them the
demonstration is in what people
including politicians with our work so
my idea is that we must go not only to
politicians we might go to social actors
member to trade unions from s bottom
ends your best moto association we must
go to the people that we study or two
people that are concerned a very sturdy
and we must create with these people a
dialog and
so it can be with politicians but matter
and if it is which politician is very
difficult it's very difficult because
formats whether i said when century ago
because when you are a social social
scientist you don't have the same
category exactly test your IDs and the
categories that where the politician you
a politician one what wants to be
reelected myself sociology system it's
not a problem so we don't have exactly
the same categories reserve which is at
stake in using I don't know if either
I'm sorry clearly what I tried to tell
you is that the importance using the
relationship and between politicians or
other actors to actors the same
underneath this relationship meaning for
me that the social scientist should
speak
because he or she has some precise
knowledge on some problem
sometimes for instance interested in
social history very present in the
newspapers so sometimes i receive
invitation to speak but sometimes event
I don't know anything about it I
remember once a very important newspaper
called me and that's me just like that
mr. give yoga what do you think you can
scar good God just go what do you think
of Eclipse car
read the newspaper yesterday before that
each less curl at being found maybe in
some subjects or carries and and I have
been making field work at that moment I
was making fever in Russia but not at
all on alki ever making fewer on post
community social movements not seem so
bad so to understand whether genetically
12 anything I have nothing of course
nothing to say Hitler's skirt so i
thought the journaling you should call
mr. McPhee oh my friend and historian
and so on and maybe a wave play some
sympathy so but this is an extreme gated
it means we should never do that we
should never answer to see scary
question me back service kind of
situation
but you should have been working on proj
community social movement and his Ariza
some see happening in one of the social
movement is good to be able to express
yourself and it's good also to be able
to express it with the people that we
maybe do something Monsieur knowledge
nor the epicenter or the ministry for
Foreign Affairs well so it's not it
obvious it's not easy but my laces the
more we can discuss present and I see
it's a little bit like the so-called
delivery or participative democracy we
can bring a lot here and so I don't
believe that the strategy somebody had
both a visitor minister and tend to the
minister while I know exactly what you
should do be with her perky sister
daughter may be other decadence to do it
but it is not like it's never like that
because my
you can talk a lot with political actors
they like to discuss an idea where they
were do nothing or what you tell them if
you don't create condition of a real
delicate ego dynamic
so not very clear what I say maybe the
DC man my parties the problem is not a
good idea the previously created
conditions of a tether that makes people
use your eyes maybe or do some signature
one two three
so obviously I you you've got to go in
you consult with contest
so what I do not like I didn't quite see
during the forecast are specifically you
want to read you
the left which
condition
bye
twice of social scientists so seven
women say that that is a long long way
communism reacts to capital captured of
them so let's open democracy the problem
is still there sure the ancestor needs
to be formulated and I do not quite see
how making the problem of the deafness
that young
Oh
the dozens of what also why finish
my heart time to reach please vote on
respond lot more too often the trend the
opposite reaction
nearly the right to announce our just to
maintain yulia these on the face of it
collections by doing
so what the left is here to do is to
come up with enough one can narrative
about a cow when you can deal with
capital and even in low light work
and I was wondering if you have some
idea they are
left
so the main problem of the left where
protest so you know as soon as the
leftover be and I think it's great for
us to hope the power that they get
well what I tried would have tried to do
to be very concrete I've been working
for the certain number of issues I
cannot work on our dental issue a method
universals spirit lvu as am I so I think
we're gonna set another on each of these
shoes is in my purse right down on each
other this issue I say if my analysis
all right my analysis is writing my data
are solely and so on Zen being led me
maybe doing this or that so I try to
make some kind of proposals I cannot be
more precise each each 20 pages of such
base but so the so called lazy pigs
built on integration on multiculturalism
on the so-called I meant issue of its
80s human right I make some proposals
which are